the investigation found the drug
industry contributed at least one and a
half million dollars to 23 lawmakers who
co-sponsored the bill weakening
enforcement laws at the height of the
opioid epidemic
congressman Tom Marino the chief
advocate for that bill is now president
Trump's nominee to be federal drug czar
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill with
information about the bill and it's key
sponsors Nancy good morning good morning
this bill was sold here on Capitol Hill
as a way to ensure that patients had
access to pain medication but former DEA
officials say that it actually stripped
their agency of its ability to go after
suspicious shipments for example when
one town of 400 people in West Virginia
got 9 million hydrocodone pills over
just two years now as Bill Whitaker
mentioned Pennsylvania's Tom Marino and
Tennessee's Marsha Blackburn introduced
this bill back in 2015 well each of them
received significant contributions that
year from the pharmaceutical industry
more than $70,000 for Murray no more
than 160,000 for Marsha Blackburn and
177 thousand dollars went to Utah
senator Orrin Hatch who negotiated this
bill with the DEA it ended up passing
with unanimous consent and signed by
President Obama former administration
officials some of them now say they
didn't realize how much this one bill
would change things we reached out to
Marino and Blackburn's offices for a
comment they did not respond senator
Hatch's office told The Washington Post
that his office actually collaborated
with the DEA and that the agency Charlie
had many opportunities to put the brakes
on this Nancy thanks